[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul and after this episode
i think i might need to crown jules as
the most complicated character in the
euphoria cast
throughout the first season she was very
much viewed as an almost toxic villain
that was a big liability hell they even
start her solo episode with the song
liability by
lord and it's clear this is very much
how the audience views her
and she views herself however after this
entry i don't think that anyone can deny
that the show completely flipped the
script
and showed that in life when it comes to
addiction there's never really any
winners
just losers we're gonna be breaking it
all down in this video but if you missed
us going over part one and need a quick
recap
then that will be linked in the pinned
comment below there'll also be heavy
spoilers here and this is something that
you should experience yourself firsthand
without some annoying british dude
telling you what happened beforehand and
ruining it
anyway if you have seen it thank you for
clicking this now let's get into part
two
okay so part one was very much a therapy
session with rue
that dug into not only her relapse but
also how
if she continued on this path that it
was destined to only go one way
it was an extremely cathartic experience
and
we see jules going through a very
similar sort of thing
but in a much more formal setting she
has been brought home by her father
after running away
and is having to face up to what she is
in a very by-the-book sort of way
now this actually shows the key
differences between rue and jewels
themselves
they are opposites in many ways and
though that leads further into their
attraction
it's clear that rue will have a
completely different experience to what
jules does
they are very much on other sides of the
track and this was of course symbolized
by the heartbreaking finale at the end
of the first
season we opened with duels played by
hunter schaefer
looking very angry and throughout this
episode we see almost a collage of
things that have made her this way
these at one point even play out on her
eyeballs and it's almost like seeing her
life flashing before her eyes
in a way that showcases she's somewhat
of a passenger in this
journey in part one rue very much blamed
jules for her issues
but as we discovered she was very much
to blame herself
i feel the same in many ways with jules
and throughout the first season
she was very much someone who was loving
to be the person that she thought she
should be
to make others like and accept her this
was seen in her online flirting with men
and in the opening monologue she states
that she became infuriated with them
because she realized that she was
building her entire self around what she
thought that men desired
her transitional journey in this episode
very much takes an alternate path
as she re-examines who she really is and
more importantly
who she wants to become jules was very
much living a lie in some ways
whereas rue was more accepting of the
person that she truly was
however this came with issues and rue
was also a burden on the character
because she placed her sobriety in her
control
jules wasn't really ready for this on
top of everything else
and in many ways the pair becoming
separated was quite liberating for her
both dr nichols and ali do a fantastic
job of bringing the pair back down to
earth
and throughout the season we've watched
as they pretty much live in an almost
manufactured reality
made up of pure fantasy even season 1
ended with a music video
rather than being the truth of the
matter which is that rue was relapsing
and therefore this motif is very much
laced in the show
jules has been part of the same sort of
scenario and has been living in a
fantasy in which she forced her life to
be a certain way
in order to live up to the expectations
of others there's a really powerful line
when she says that she feels like real
life is always such a letdown
and this clearly paints out the
psychological state of her mind
jules clearly found online relationships
better than the real thing
especially because she could manipulate
the fantasy to her own liking
however the truth about tyler coming out
was completely horrifying
and she would have rather remained in
the fabrication than to have experienced
this terror first hand
this further ties into the idea that she
wants to live in a controlled
environment
that is exactly the way she can fake it
and so on
she says the best sex she ever had was
through sexting and this is because it
was pure imagination
not something that existed with any
tangibility
throughout the session she also examines
her own femininity
and almost tries to map out the best way
to transition to become the person that
she needs to be
rather than the person that she wanted
to it becomes clear that though she
never really stated until now
jules has very much been crying out for
help but up until this first therapy
session
she simply hasn't got it jules even
states that she prays to the ocean
in a scene that is probably worth
winning an emmy for alone
now this mirrors rue as in part one she
said that she was an atheist that found
a higher power in things
well exactly like the ocean jules states
for her that transitioning is spiritual
and the two are going on parallel
journeys in several ways
due to the absence of a parental figure
now jules's mother becomes a big talking
point
and it becomes clear that jules turned
to herself and the elements
rather than to her jules's mother amy is
also an addict
and in retrospect it massively changes
how we view both rue and jules's
relationship
she created an imbalance in their love
and the self-centered mother who
couldn't see her own addiction affected
her child
has clearly been repeated through the
actions of jewels
we learned that around the time of the
halloween party that her mother relapsed
and this massively changed how i think
jewels comes across
so far throughout all of euphoria
everything has pretty much always been
through the eyes of rue
and jules has been a goal rather than a
character
who we're able to understand and relate
to we realize that jules actually does
love rue
but that she was scared that she loved
her too much and due to her relationship
with her mother
she knew that there was a huge potential
for heartbreak there
which she didn't feel strong enough to
go through again
now this new information that we get not
only about her mother but also the other
aspects of her life
completely recontextualize certain
things and lead us to having a better
appreciation for why jules ran away
it's clear she didn't want to go back to
this whole cycle where
a female figure was burdening themselves
upon her and i think that she was
worried about history repeating itself
through jules continuing the cycle you
can totally understand why she didn't
get off the train to be withdrew
and it makes the character so much more
relatable
we sort of see a continuation of the
fantasy from last time
and reveal that it would have led to rue
oding because of the cycle that they
existed in
the episode culminates with ruined
jewels coming face to face once more
before the former goes to meet ali as we
know she received an i love you text
from her
but the events that would follow show
that perhaps they aren't meant to be
together
it's a really tearful reunion and rather
than facing things head-on and what
they've been through
real leaves before the pair can really
confront what's going on between them
they clearly need each other but neither
can bear to be here again
and much like the ending of part one we
close out staring at our protagonists
through a rain-soaked window
as the world closes in around them it's
such a bitter way to close things out
and you really get the feeling that the
things they've been through together
might have pushed a wedge further
between them overall though
this was an incredible episode yet again
and i actually prefer these character
focused entries
over the main season and i wish i'm bad
admitting that but
i don't know why i just think that the
pandemic has actually pushed the writing
to be more personable
and they've managed to do a lot more
with a lot less
euphoria deserves all the emmys right
now and this was another incredible
entry that i'd love to hear your
thoughts on
now don't forget that on the 30th of
january we're giving away three copies
of the hobbit and lord of the rings 4k
box sets to our subscribers
all you have to do to begin with the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the episode
the links to our socials are in the
description and you can also support the
channel by clicking the join button and
as a thank you you get videos like this
early
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
part 1 which will be linked on screen
right now
we went over the entire thing and with
this episode
i think a lot of the scenes in it have a
lot more weight to them
so it's definitely worth checking out if
you're coming off the back of this
if not then thank you for sitting
through the video as always i've been
paul
you've been the best and i'll see you
next time take care peace